وجهه نظر عسكريه من هذه الحادثه بالتفاصيل
المعلنه ونذكر مره اخرى من طرف الجيش الذي
يجعل
منها منحن في مسار
الحرب نعم لا شك بان هذه الحادثه يمكن ان
تشكل منحنى خطير في مساله الحرب يعني هناك
ثلاثه نقاط رئيسيه النقطه الاولى هو بان
تكون كلفه الخسائر كبيره جدا بحيث لا
يتحملها الجيش القضيه الثانيه بان
الاقتصاد لا يساعد على الاستمرار في هذه
العمليه القضيه الثالثه هي قضيه الاسرى
الذي يمكن ان تكون ضاغطه وتؤدي الى ايقاف
هذه الحرب التي تجري في قطاع غزه ولكن
دعني قبل هذا كله ان اناقش بعض النقاط
المهمه يعني لان انا اميل الى الروايه
التي يمكن ان تصدر من كتائب القسام في هذا
الامر يعني الامر الاول بانه اذا ما جئنا
الى مراقبه الاوضاع بشكل كامل يعني فيما
يخص ملف الاسرى نجد بانه هناك نقطه مهمه
جدا يعني سواء كانت في قضيه مقتل ساعر
باروخ او الان في هؤلاء الثلاثه اولا بان
الاسرى لا يتواجدون في منطقه واحده وانما
موزعين على مناطق متفرقه وهذه المناطق قد
يكون فيها اسير واحد وقد تكون فيها ثلاثه
اسر كما جرى الامر الثاني عندما نتكلم عن
الاعلام البيضاء نقول من جاء بالاعلام
البيضاء لهؤلاء الاسرى اذا هناك قضيه
مدبره وهناك امر تم ترتيبه من خلال هؤلاء
الاسرى لايصال رساله معينه من قبل كتائب
القسام الامر الثالث بان دائما الاسرى
عندما يكونون يكونون مقيدين بحيث لا يمكن
لهم الحركه خصوصا وانك متواجد في منطقه
عسكريه ومنطقه قتال محتدم
مضاريع الامر بشكل كامل بانه مخطط له بشكل
كبير جدا من قبل الكتائب القسام وفصائل
المقاومه لايصال شيء لانه عمليه قتل هؤلاء
هناك رساله واضحه بان حكومه نتن ياهو غير
معنيه بهؤلاء الاسرى والدليل بانه تم
قتلهم بنيران اسرائيليه بنيران الجيش
الصهيوني وهذا يعكس مدى الرعب والخوف
الكبير جدا الذي ينتاب المقاتلين في ساحه
المعركه سواء كان على مستوى القيادات او
على مستوى الافراد خصوصا وانه في سياقات
الجيش هناك اوامر تسمى اوامر السيطره على
النار عندما يتم ايقاف اوامر السيطره على
النار لا يمكن لاحد ان يفتح هذه النار الا
بصدور اوامر اخرى طيب عندما تم قتل
الاثنين لماذا تم قتل الثالث من قبل
الجندي هذا يعكس حاله الرعب والخوف
والتخبط والارتباك الكبير يضاف الى ذلك
بانه الكمائن التي وضعت مثل ما قلنا في
قبل قليل في في هذه المنطقه او في مناطق
اخرى جعلت الجيش الصهيوني يرى بان هذه
المنطقه بيئه معاديه بشكل كامل فهو لا يثق
باي شيء سواء كان مقاتل او سواء كان منزل
او سواء كان دار او سواء كان طريق
وبالتالي هو يحاول ان ان يقوم بعمليه
الرمي لتامين اقل شيء من الحمايه او
الامان لنفسه وهذا ما جعل هذه الخسائر
تسقط يضاف الى ذلك بان هذا الامر قد يكون
هو تخريجه من قبل قوات الاحتلال التي سعرت
الى الاعلان قبل كتاب القسام في هذا الامر
الى انها تريد مخرج لما يجري الان في في
خصوصا ونحن في المرحله الثانيه يعني عندما
نتكلم في المرحله الاولى التي انتهت مع
الهدنه وبدانا بالمرحله الثانيه هي مرحله
التوازن او التعادل الاستراتيجي ما بين
الطرفين
فالطرق اهداف هذه الحرب هناك هناك طرف
مهاجم يحاول كان كان الهجوم في البدايه
بقبضه واحده الان الهجوم بقبضت قبضه في
الشمال وقبضه في الجنوب اذا هو في المعركه
الاولى حاول ان يركز جهده الحربي بشكل
كبير جدا على منطقه ضيقه واحده ولكنه فشل
في تحقيق الاهداف ثم بعد ذلك عاد ليذهب
الى الى جهه اخرى الى الجنوب ففصل قواته
الى قوتين لعله ان يكون فصل القوات
باتجاهين اضعف يضعف ويربك الموضع
الدفاعي الموجود في داخل قطاع غزه هذا
الامر ايضا لم ينجح والدليل على هذا بانه
المعارك تحتدم بشكل كبير جدا نسبه الخسائر
ترتفع سواء كانت في الاليات او في المعدات
او في القوى البشريه يضاف الى ذلك بان
هناك اشكال حقيقي في مساله الوصول الى
الاسرى على الرغم من التسريبات التي تقول
بانه بداوا مل الانفاق بالمياه وما الى
ذلك من تصورات اخرى اذا نحن نقول بان هناك
ترتيب لهذا الامر ولكن يبدو بان الطعم
اكلته اكلته القوات الصهيونيه في هذا
وابتلعته في هذه المساله وقامت بقتل هؤلاء
الاسرى
لذلك وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تنقل عن
ضابط اسرائيلي
بارز انهم لم يكونوا مستعدين سيناريو
يتجول خلاله المختطفون بحريه في شوارع غزه
طبعا هذا الضابط يشير الى الحادثه وروايه
الجيش والتحقيق الاولي عن وجود مختطفين او
محتجزين في غزه يرفعون الرايه البيضاء
وبالتالي ليست هنالك ربما تكون معلومات او
تعليمات في كيفيه التعامل معهم و وهذا
يعزز في نفس الروايه روايه المفاجاه انت
كيف تقرا هذه التسريبات للصحف والتي كما
قلنا هي نقلا عن ضابط
اسرائيلي طيب حتى لو كان الامر بهذا
الترتيب يعني هذا لا يجعل الاخرين
باستخدام اسلحتهم لقتل هؤلاء لانه يجب ان
تكون هناك نسبه من التوقع ونسبه من
الاحتمالات تقول بان هؤلاء قد يكونون هم
اسرى وتم اطلاق سراحهم مثل ما تقول مثل ما
تكلمت الروايه الاولى بانه هناك اشخاص
رفعوا الاعلام وما الى ذلك اذا لا يمكن
لهم ان يتعاملوا بمساله النار المباشره
لقتل هؤلاء يعني يجب ان تكون هناك نسبه من
التوقع والاحتمال بان هؤلاء فعلا هم اسرى
ولكن لماذا فعل الجيش الصهيوني هذا الامر
وبادر الى قتلهم بصوره مباشره هنا علامات
الاستفهام تظهر بشكل كبير جدا هل هو خطا
ارتكبته القياده العسكريه او الجيش الذي
موجود في هذه المنطقه ام هناك تعمد في
مساله هذه القضيه ام ان هذا الامر كان فيه
شكوك بان هؤلاء هو كمين من قبل كتائب
القسام وفصائل المقاومه ويمكن ان يؤدي الى
جر القوه الى منطقه قتل منتخبه وبالتالي
يمكن ان يكون هناك اشكال حقيقي علما اني
اشكك بهذه القضيه بانه لا اعتقد بان فصائل
القسام تستخدم الاسرى في في مسائل لجر
العدو الى منطقه قتل منتخبه لان اصلا
المعارك تحتدم بشكل كبير جدا والخسائر
كبيره بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال سواء كانت في
الاليات او سواء كانت في المعدات والقوه
البشريه و وبالاضافه الى ذلك الجيش تحدث
بالاضافه طبعا للاخبار العاجله والتسريبات
للصحف الجيش تحدث حتى في تحقيقه الاولي عن
ان الحادث يخالف قواعد الاشتباك فما هي
القواعد
اصلا في التعامل سواء مع الاسرى او حتى
المقاتلين على هذه الصوره التي رسمت في
تحقيق الجيش رايه
بيضاء نعم هذه القضيه يعني عندما يقول
يخالف التعليمات او يخالف قواعد الاشتباك
طيب انتم خلينا الهدف الرئيسي من هذه
العمليه العسكريه هو انقاذ الاسرى اذا انت
تتقدم لتنفيذ هدف من اهداف الحرب بانقاذ
الاسرى من في قطاع غزه عندما يظهرون اناس
ويرفعون اعلام بيضاء ويتكلمون اللغه
العبريه ويقولون انقذونا طيب هل هل يمكن
لك ان تبادر بقتل هؤلاء اذا لماذا اذا كان
الامر بهذا الترتيب لماذا انطلقت هذه
العمليه العسكريه وتضع احد اهدافها هو
تحرير الاسرى هذا تناقض كبير جدا في
الروايه الاسرائيليه لا يمكن ان تكون
الامور بهذا الترتيب الذي يحاولون وصفه او
يحاولون ايجاد تخريجه له بسبب مقتل هؤلاء
الاسرى